people of the internet's retro Records
who are here I'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell and
Harry Potter magic awakened is
officially out the global release date
just happened I am not a fan of mobile
games I do not play a lot of mobile
games at all so I really didn't know
what to expect in terms of if I was
going to enjoy the kind of core gameplay
Loop of this or not and I am very
pleasantly surprised so far you guys I
know right shocker coming from a guy who
loves Harry Potter oh my gosh let's go
yes boom there we go
gryffindle dude look at his character
model man so good Epic
no way that's right no matter where you
are at in the world you can now play
Harry Potter magic waited on iOS or
Android there's also some ways to get it
running on PC right now when it's
working we'll get to that in a second
but first Just My overall honest
impressions for the game over time I may
end up saying hey this isn't for me long
term it was fun while it lasted but
right now just on the beginning I am
really liking it so far there are a lot
of deep mechanics here that I think
traditional Gamers whatever that means
anymore I don't know there are so many
mobile Gamers and PC Gamers and console
Gamers these days but I do think there's
a very clear difference between games
that are developed as a mobile game and
games that are developed as more of a
Home console type of game and I've been
kind of surprised there hasn't been more
excitement for this game I knew
something was up when I ran a poll back
here in early June and keep in mind our
channel has been heavily focused on
games in the Wizarding World this poll
had almost 7 500 votes and 76 percent of
you said you hadn't even heard of Harry
Potter magic awaken which is just insane
I've also seen a lot of confusion even
among Wizarding World fans some people
thought this was actually the Quidditch
Champions game some people have gotten
confused with Harry Potter Hogwarts
mystery the other mobile game so let's
start with just some facts here this is
an RPG card based combat game and it is
also an MMO so it's actually blending a
few different styles together here yes
there is multiplayer yes you can play
with your friends yes you can actually
see other players in the world and
that's honestly been one of the most
exciting parts for me about this game so
far is seeing other players seeing you
guys our community here in The Wizarding
World together I think that aspect is
going to continue to be a lot of fun so
the game in terms of story is set 10
years after Harry Potter's victory over
Voldemort in the Battle of Hogwarts now
you may be wondering well wait I've seen
Harry Potter I've seen Dumbledore in
some of the trailers and things like
that what's going on there and that is
true there are things in the game where
you will actually be able to relive some
of the most iconic moments from the
books which I absolutely love this right
now you're seeing the very first one
that happened and you're seeing me get
to play Dumbledore versus Voldemort
reliving that epic duel in the ministry
of magic and obviously this is set up as
a card based battle rather than like a
third person Action Battle but I still
loved getting to relive this moment with
kind of a different lens on it it's
absolutely hilarious to watch Voldemort
just cast a vatica davra over and over
and over again
but then you have the spell with
Dumbledore where you can actually get
these knights in front of you also that
giant orb of water spell that Dumbledore
uses yeah that's in here apparently it's
just called
so the combat has actually been really
fun so far and I feel like it's gonna
get incredibly deep incredibly strategic
the more you play the game so far right
now it hasn't been too challenging but
keep in mind I am just a few hours in
now your character you actually do get
to create and make your own character
our journey starts similar to Harry's
actually Hagrid's gonna show up deliver
your letter of acceptance he's going to
show you the ropes of The Wizarding
World and take you to dying on alley and
it's here where you first start to get a
sense of how the game is set up how you
can actually explore this world and for
people who have played Hogwarts Legacy
and may be interested in this this is
also a good chance to see how these
games are different now of course
Hogwarts Legacy didn't even have Diagon
Alley but if it did you know it would
have been like a fully explorable area
think about hogsmead and how that works
in Hogwarts Legacy here you can roam
around a little bit but you can't go
into every shop you can't talk to every
single person some of the people you can
talk to and then there are invisible
barriers here throughout where you just
hit a wall and then you can't go any
further so the exploration aspect is
certainly much more limited than a game
like Hogwarts Legacy now one of the big
features that this game has that
Hogwarts Legacy does not have is this
whole Community aspect I'm still
learning about the game so I don't even
know how many different things we can do
so far I've joined a dorm with you guys
you're actually limited to just four
people in your dorm so be very careful
about who you choose you have to make
sure you're of the same server the same
house and the same gender you can also
join a social club we've set up one for
house rack and tour we'd love to have
you if you want to join and if you're
interested at all in that you actually
can't do it at the beginning of the game
you do have to progress to a certain
point and it's actually going to ask you
hey do you want to join one of these
Social Clubs just search hours out keep
in mind there are only 50 total spots
we'll see how many we end up having I
don't know we might have to open up some
additional ones but another cool aspect
is you can actually compete so we're
going to earn points together as a club
and we'll actually get ranked on a
global leaderboard so yes you will get
to choose your Hogwarts house as well
well you're going to be attending
classes exploring the castle somewhat
there is a dueling Club as well and most
of the action especially when it comes
to the spell casting everything is
centered around this card-based combat
system and it's not just spells that
you're going to be collecting like I
have a card here for Monster Book of
monsters so you like summon these
Monster books and send them out to do
battle for you you can also do spiders
and trolls and who knows what else I
mean I'm still very early in the game so
I think the collectibility of all these
items plus the community aspect that is
what they're really hoping is going to
keep people coming back to this game
especially when it comes to all these
PVE activities that we can actually do
together as a group now a lot of people
have talked about the art style some
people love it some people hate it I'm
actually in the love at Camp I think
it's great to have a completely
different take a completely new look on
the Wizarding World it's just such an
iconic world and I know a lot of people
have just this Clear Vision of what it
looks like in their head but I frankly
love stuff like this when you get a
completely different interpretation of a
world that you already know it actually
reminds me of all the different Harry
Potter book covers you know the books
have been translated into so many
different languages and something people
don't even know these exist I mean check
out these tie covers I think these are
some of the most beautiful covers of any
of the books any language but the world
itself looks different this artist
interpreted it very differently than
Mary Grand pray here in the U.S for
example so I think the r style is great
now the setup that I was having to do to
actually get this to run was kind of
crazy and I could not believe how good
it looked so I was actually playing the
game on my iPhone mirroring that to my
MacBook Air and then capturing that
through an HDMI capture card on my PC
and that's how I was able to stream it
so I could actually see the game in
front of me on a 27 inch 1440p monitor
and it actually looked great I cannot
believe how great this looked and I
gotta say if anyone from WB or netease
out there is actually listening to this
please please please try and get the PC
client ready ASAP because I really do
think that you'll be able to bring in a
lot of new players if you could say hey
this is a PC game because right now
especially with a lot of the Hogwarts
Legacy fans there's just this stigma
against mobile games right stigma
against all these micro transactions but
having the ability to just download this
straight to your PC and try it
completely for free honestly more than
anything I want it for a better
controller support I want to be able to
use my mouse and keyboard instead of
having to use all the little touch
controls on the actual phone and who
knows maybe one day we'll even get
controller support I'd absolutely love
that however I will say there are a lot
of features in the game that do seem to
require at least a mouse or touch screen
to be able to do for example the Yule
Ball dancing minigame giving me
flashbacks to Elite beat agents man one
of my favorite Nintendo DS games of all
time I think if this game was on Console
even with all the micro transactions
which there are a lot of micro
transactions I will say though I have
not felt like I needed to buy anything
yet a lot of it looks like Cosmetics now
I have heard from people who've been
playing the game for a while that where
it does kind of become pay to win is if
you really want to be top tier in the
PVP so there are absolutely plenty of
options here to spend money and the game
doesn't shy away from that it's not like
it tries to hide it or anything so you
know get that out of the way first it is
a mobile game developed with that style
of hey this is free to play but if you
want to have a lot of these extra things
particularly when it comes to cosmet
Medics and more cards then
microtransactions are involved now a lot
of times the way these games are set up
is that you can do something or get some
type of card much faster by paying money
than you could otherwise you still be
able to get all the same things just by
playing the game normally but it could
take you a very long time to do so and
I'm still learning all the currencies
there's a lot of currencies in this game
they're Keys they're golden keys and
then silver keys and then there are gyms
and then there's gold so I know there's
been a lot of confusion on if you could
play it on PC or if you can I'm actually
going to make a separate video on that
because you can actually play the game
on a PC right now through Android
emulators and this is not like anything
shady anything that breaks terms of
service this is actually what I started
playing on my stream I was using an app
called BlueStacks and at the beginning
it was working incredibly well
unfortunately I don't know if it's
because so many people were trying to
play the game on launch day or what but
a lot of these emulators just started to
crash I would not run the game at all so
that's why I had to end up doing that
crazy setup using my phone and the
screen mirroring all that now if you're
on a Mac you may think hey I can't all
Max with an M1 chip or higher run iPhone
phone slash iPad apps and the answer is
yes however this is something that the
developer has to enable I didn't realize
this I thought it was just an automatic
thing because I remember Apple making a
big deal about this when they created
the new M1 Max is the fact that they
could run any iPhone or iPad app and
unfortunately the app is just not there
even when you're looking at the iPhone
and iPad apps so I don't know how
difficult that is if that's just a
switch that someone at Netties needs to
say okay we need to check that box or if
it's actually something that they have
to program in but if it's an easy thing
again WB netease please just enable that
I think that would make it a lot easier
for people playing on the Mac and there
is an official PC client coming so you
will be able to play this game on a PC
at some point downloading it directly to
your computer however we don't know when
I saw that the HP magic awake and
Twitter account was actually answering
some people and they said it is coming
but they do not have a date yet also if
I can get a little crazy for a second I
think this game would be absolutely
incredible on a Nintendo switch just
saying I think it'd be great you already
got the touch screen right there so
absolutely yes it is still early we'll
see how I feel about this game in a week
and a month if I'm still playing it or
not but right now I'm having an absolute
blast so make sure you subscribe to the
channel you don't miss any of our live
streams and also if you hear all this
and you're a big fan of the Wizarding
World and you still think hey I'm just
not interested you should know there is
still a separate Harry Potter game
coming Harry Potter quid of Champions we
don't have a date for it yet and there's
a lot of things that I think they're
gonna need to tweak with quidditch to
make that game good actually I already
have a video up on that you can check it
out on the right side of your screen
next as always guys thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon